bonjour bonjour
bienvenue
et pourquoi est-ce qu'il est fier comme
ça c'est parce qu'il a participé à de
nombreux concours
et même de grands concours
il en a fait deux très connus ici
et c'est vrai que
il a un regard on sent que c'est pas
ça rigole pas quoi
il en impose
c'est une petite ville tranquille du
nord de l'Angleterre dont la quiétude
est perturbée depuis quelques temps par
de nouveaux occupants des habitants à
plume qui se font la cour pavane dans
les rues sans aucune notion de la
propriété privée il s'invite chez tous
les voisins
la première fois que je les ai vu par la
fenêtre je me suis dit qu'est-ce qu'il
m'arrive ce sont des Français mais ce
sont des Français par leur identité et
malheureusement pour la deuxième la
troisième génération il y a comme une
sorte de régression vers les origines
vers les origines ethniques une sorte de
régression vers les origines ethniques à
l'origine il n'y avait que trois pans
dans cet hôtel qui a fermé ses portes il
y a 5 ans depuis ils se sont multipliés
le quartier en compet une trentaine
aujourd'hui 1% de sa population humaine
chez Jim Mitchell il y en a partout
je leur parle et il me regarde et quand
je vais sur ma terrasse il défèque sur
ma tête mais quelle belle oiseaux c'est
mieux qu'ils font un peu aujourd'hui
force est de constater que oui vous
allez me dire la plupart des gens qui
sont qui ont été arrêtés sont français
d'accord mais ça ne veut plus rien dire
aujourd'hui ils sont comment en français
et moi ça m'interroge certains ne
veulent même plus en entendre parler ils
ont rayé ma voiture allez vous en les
pans on se met la zizanie dans ce
village qui s'affrontent maintenant à
coup de pétition l'une pour les capturer
et les confier à un refuge l'autre pour
les laisser prospérer sans toucher à une
plume de ses oiseaux
c'est cette dernière pétition qui a pour
leur récolté le plus de soutien il nous
explique que donc les émeutes c'est pas
un immigration puisque c'est Kévin Matéo
on se dit mais bon sang mais au sommet
de l'État il y a que des maris Chantal
et des Pinocchio avec le nez qui
s'allonge au fur et à mesure qu'il monte
comment est-ce qu'on peut dire aux
Français qui ont vu les images des
émeutes de ces razziens comment est-ce
que vous pouvez leur dire sérieusement
que ça n'a aucun rapport avec
l'immigration évidemment que ce sont des
enfants de l'immigration c'est la
journée internationale du baiser dans
l'Antiquité c'était une marque de
reconnaissance sociale au Moyen-Âge
c'est devenu un geste réservé à l'amour
entre un homme et une femme et
aujourd'hui il a de multiples
significats de tendresse d'affection ou
symbole de passion il est principalement
échangé dans l'intimité mais parfois
aussi entre collègues
avant il y avait la prière vous avez dit
que c'est pas bon avant les parents
pouvaient reprendre leurs enfants mais
leur donner une tape s'il le mérite vous
avez dit il faut pas le faire vous les
mettez même en garde à vue quand ils le
font
vous avez empêché aux parents d'élever
les enfants convenablement
à l'école vous avez dit si on donne 0 à
un enfant vous le traumatisez
le bisou peut évidemment transmettre des
maladies mais il est aussi bon pour la
santé puisqu'il fait travailler nos
muscles et qu'il renforce nos défenses
immunitaires alors n'hésitez pas je vous
demande de revenir de demander à Dieu un
peu de sagesse parce que vous n'auriez
pas agi ainsi si vous étiez adressé à
lui lui il est celui qui est capable de
vous donner tout intelligence pour mener
à bien un pays mais non vous avez rejeté
Dieu
et bien aujourd'hui voilà ce qui arrive
aujourd'hui sur le boomerang ça vous
revient
c'est la durée idéale minimum d'un
baiser pour établir un lien avec son
partenaire il est recommandé au couple
de s'embrasser six secondes plusieurs
fois par jour pour créer une bonne
connexion et ça peut aussi diminuer le
stress de la vie quotidienne
les premiers éléments que nous avons
recueillis permettent de retracer les
dernières minutes de Mohamed samedi à
minuit 49 il est devant le magasin
Volcom de la rue Montgrand il filme une
interpellation sans doute liée aux
émeutes 26 minutes plus tard à 1h15 il
est retrouvé inanimé en bas de
l'immeuble de sa mère il est en arrêt
cardio-respiratoire les pompiers ne
parviennent pas à le réanimer selon le
parquet de Marseille la vraie
semblablement été victime d'un choc
violent au thorax sans doute causé par
un tir de flash-ball après cette étude
quand on demande aux personnes
interrogées qui sort renforcés de cette
séquence c'est le nom de Marine Le Pen
qui est cité dans 50% des cas les
républicains ne on choisit que par 20%
des sondées la nuit pèse par 11% et
Emmanuel Macron et le gouvernement par
9% pour nous il
a été et moi je trouve ça
que même la police tout ça ça avait déjà
qui qu'il était décédé par un policier
mais il ne voulait pas nous le dire
qu'il était décédé d'un cuir pour le
moment rien ne permet d'affirmer que
Mohamed participait aux émeutes ce que
l'on sait c'est qu'il se trouvait à
proximité immédiate de la rue
Saint-Ferréol théâtre de nombreux
pillages et dégradations le week-end
dernier ses proches décrivent un homme
travailleur
bloquer les réseaux sociaux
et partiellement l'idée a été lancée par
le président devant les maires des
communes qui ont été frappées par les
violences urbaines mais pour cet avocate
cela pose un problème légal pour donner
quelques exemples de pays qui ont bloqué
les réseaux sociaux on peut citer par
exemple la Chine l'Iran ou la Corée du
Nord mais en aucun cas un pays
démocratique est de loin la France
puisque en France il existe des textes
constitutionnels européens qui protègent
la liberté d'expression
bien en trouver là où on peut se sourire
[Musique]
la liberté d'expression principe
fondamentale mais pendant les émeutes
les réseaux sociaux TikTok Instagram
Twitter et autres ont aussi servi de
relais aux émeutiers dès lors quelle
règle doit prévaloir et que la
Constitution garantisse la liberté
d'expression ça me paraît absolument
fondamental mais je pense que c'est
faire une erreur que considérer que ces
entreprises privées sont les garantes de
la démocratie et de la Constitution ces
réseaux sont devenus un nouvel outil de
la mobilisation y compris quand la
mobilisation et bah dépasse le cadre de
la loi voici 2 g
allez 2 g dans la grève bon ça c'est une
trompette mais c'est pas grave c'est la
copine du bulle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est une folie une folie la musique est
à fond
il y a les gens qui dansent les moutons
qui se battent c'est une sorte de boîte
de nuit de jour sur ambiance de Battle
de bélier